hello today I'm gonna tell you a story
about something that happened to me that
was really really bad
so enjoy here in the United Kingdom we
have this charity called comic relief
who every two years butts on this big
event called Red Nose Day as depicted
here
it's a massive TV event designed to
entertain the nation while also helping
to raise lots of money for good causes
here in the UK and in Africa now fairly
recently comic relief got in touch with
me and said hello Charlie is so cool
like we need to be better at making
YouTube videos can you help us and I was
like sure thing bro
they don't call me Charlie is so given
like for nothing I'm always up for
helping a good cause
and they were like oh thank you young
man how lovely you are and that's
exactly how it happened
so I went to go meet with comic relief
or they were like you wanna make a
YouTube video for us no I was like sure
and then they were like oh by the way
there are any celebrities that you're
interested in doing something with for
this video because if we ask nicely we
might be able to get one for you so they
weren't really just saying do you want
to make a video for a good cause they
were also saying pick a celebrity that
you want to meet and we might be able to
have them come around your flat so you
could make a video with them and that's
what happened sort of I told him that
was a massive fan of this big musical
comedian called Tim Minchin and that in
an ideal world I'd like to just write a
song with him not thinking that would
happen obviously but they came back to
me and said sure Tim Minchin is
interested when do you want to start and
I said so I wrote a song of Tim which
was lovely and then on the day before he
was meant to fly out to Australia he
came around to my flat to film it which
was a bit mental I insisted that we
learned the song and so we spent about
four hours trying to get a take of it
when he was only meant to stay over for
about an hour and a half that was also a
bit crazy we finally get the take Tim
flies back to Australia never to be seen
again I'm very aware of the fact that we
probably won't have another chance to do
this then I sit down in front of my
laptop to look at the footage that we
just got and this is what I see
so it turns out that I forgot to turn
the microphone on desk then I get an
email from Tim Minchin that says you're
right charlie I had fun today I hope you
did as well can you send me the video
and I don't respond to him because I
don't know what to say to him then comic
relief get in touch and say how did the
shoot go and I say we'd had slight audio
problems and they say oh oh dear what
could we do to help and I say we forgot
to turn the microphone on I'm an idiot
there's nothing we can do it happened
quite a while ago now so I've managed to
distance myself from the experience a
bit but just retelling the story is
making me relive the emotions and oh it
was so bad now I could just make a video
of Tim Minchin and then not tell you
about the video that I made with Tim
Minchin because it was a pretty good
video apart from the bit where I peed
all over it we had this cool thing
prepared for it where it's gonna start
off like a normal song of mine and then
the camera was gonna pan across and then
oh my god Tim Minchin is rolling in two
shots every one Tim Minchin every one
Tim mentioned although the effect
would've been partially dampened by the
fact you can actually see Tim's
reflection in my computer screen before
he even rolls into shorts to do that
effect by the way where Tim rolls into
short my flatmate Alex had to lie on his
stomach and push him in and then once he
was done he had to kind of lie there out
of shot on the floor for the duration of
the whole thing I liked to get Alex to
do little humiliating jobs for me like
that but I think he secretly enjoyed it
being underneath Tim Minchin
and ultimately I realized the best thing
I could do with this situation was just
tell you the tale of the whole thing so
you can revel in my misfortune because
if nothing else it's quite a good story
the tagline for comic relief is do
something funny for money so at this
point I was gonna say we just did
something funny for money now it's your
turn but now I have to say I try to do
something funny for money but failed
miserably now it's your turn to make up
for my mistakes so if you'd like to
raise some money for charity and do
something for comic relief this Red Nose
daily you can go to Red Nose name.com
forward slash fundraise I wish you good
luck I hope you do better than I did and
I will see you at a point in the future
good bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool